first i'm gonna break all the virtual
junket rules and i'm gonna pose a
question to all three of you
do you
make the bed every morning never make it
or is it a chaotic mixture of the two
and i didn't realize how much number
three stressed me out until i watched
the show
i'm a chaotic mixture
me too i'm either in the mood or i'm not
three
if i'm feeling real bad i'll make my bed
to try and make myself feel better but
usually it just gets left
i can't believe all three of you went
for it i'm i'm not i change my sheets
really frequently though
same i'm really good at that so
sometimes it doesn't feel worth it to
make the bed if i'm just going to change
the sheets
you know what i like that excuse that
balances out that answer a little i
appreciate it all right one more of
these for all three of you what was your
best
best
birthday
my 21st
yeah
yeah why
um
well because like it was my last uh it
was my last day in new zealand
it was like a very like bittersweet
moment saying goodbye but and going home
at the same time like
i don't know i just like that one but
for
personal reasons
how cute
mine was my 14th
i had um
uh like kitty like very it was a dora
theme
birthday and you know because i was all
too old to be into those kind of things
but i wanted because it made it cool
that i was into it you know because i
was 14. um and people are like wow you
should feel lame that you got a bouncy
castle but it wasn't because they all
actually really secretly love bounty
castles because she doesn't come on yeah
um you're not too old for that i would
still have a bouncy castle at this age
oh my god you could yeah like i would
feel like i would break it now but at 14
i was jumping in that thing all night
all right shannon can you top that
i don't think i could top a bouncy
castle but for my 16th i had a
winter like a christmas in july themed
murder mystery
party
so everyone was dressed up as like
experts
and it was a murder mystery party so i
was like who done it was it rudolph the
gingerbread man was it santa
i dressed up as mrs claus and it was it
was beautiful my parents went all out
there
i got all actors as friends
did you have all actors as friends
no everyone else was real confused by
you're the one actor that's like guys
we're gonna do a thing let's do it we're
gonna do
i like this i mean i'm either going to
new zealand i'm having a murder mystery
party or i'm getting the bouncy castle
for my next three at once babe
that is what i'm doing to celebrate
all right let's get into specifics now
sophia i'll come to you first so one of
my absolute favorite things about season
two is getting the chance to see the
characters grow based on how they've
influenced each other and one of the
ones that stands out to me big time is
how fatten kind of you know takes the
baton from leah and really runs with it
so was there anything that you saw sarah
do playing that role in season one that
you found in forming your own
performance as she's kind of figuring
out the mystery in season two i think
that the difference between sarah and
fatten is that um
satin through whatever
experiences she's had has had to like
really understand herself like really
actually figure out who she is and um
she has done so
much because it's
it's so
like not okay in her family you know to
be the way that she is um like coming
from a muslim family you know and so i
think that's probably why she feels so
like convicted in who she is and why she
does she's not ashamed of it um
but leah you know she hasn't had those
things pulling her back so i think that
the levels of her
sort of realizing and and crazy i don't
mean in a negative way i think that
crazy people are
um probably really really smart uh
but um yeah so like the layers of her
being crazy and like the way that
figuring out that the island wasn't real
um or you weren't we the crash wasn't
real really messed with her head you
know but fatten um
she just had more of a
built up
like a way to accept weird things does
that make sense does that make any sense
it does i still wasn't expecting phantom
to go down that path but you earn it
really well i loved that arc for her all
right jenna so now for you i was
wondering did you always know that
martha was gonna get off the island or
was there any point while you were
making season one or maybe even between
seasons before you got the season two
script that you're like uh oh like this
could be it
uh i mean it was there was always that
question is she alive and all that um
conspiracy but um
i was really happy because i feel her
story
is not finished she has a lot to
overcome and grow from
um from what we've learned from season
one she's a sexual assault survivor
and
i feel there is no end to that so for me
to keep playing that i feel very
i don't even know to say not happy about
it but i'm
grateful that i can tell a story to like
make other people comfortable
with their own traumas or even just have
something that they relate to spoiler
question for you now shannon so
there's like one particular moment i
wanted to focus on and
typically it's like what happens to dot
when martha goes into that catatonic
state because i have i have tony's
speech yelling at her kind of drilled
into my brain so for you playing a
moment like that
is that specific thing happening really
something that threatens dots you know
tenacity and know-how or is it a
combination of everything i think in the
moment that like
and specifically talking about um tony
going off on on dart in those moments i
think
the the frustration that came from dot
is i think it's just kind of like the
they've been through so much already and
this is a pattern for her in her life
she's discovering that
she she's always around people where she
can't she can't fix it she can do all
she can to help but she can't she can't
take the pain away she can't take it on
for them and so then when tony turns
around and is like yeah you're being a
bleak [ __ ] and you're not helping like
you should be
i think it comes with a a lot of shame
for doc because that is who she was for
so long but when is she ever able to
kind of tap out and just sit in the [ __ ]
and be like this is a really [ __ ]
situation i feel really [ __ ] and
i'm exhausted and i don't know what to
do
um
a real moment of like tenacity for her
and i think it was it was fun to kind of
explore this
this this turmoil the push and pull of
um
kind of her instincts versus just the
the tiredness and the exhaustiveness of
the situation it was all spoiled with
eight minutes to talk to you guys but i
have a mile long list of questions that
hopefully we'll get to in the future i'm
obsessed with your show season day with
killer yet again thanks congratulations
good to see you again you too hopefully
we'll do this again soon